well I guess the start off with our
Dumbo what is the worst nickname anyone
has ever given to you I don't know I
recollection when I was a kid they
actually used to call me Dumbo that's
that must be that must get you right now
part in the heartstrings well you know
people are afraid and they're upset and
they're don't they know what to think
about people who are different than they
are it doesn't matter whether you're a
human being or an elephant or whatever
they just you know sometimes need to be
you know evolved into something better
we hope sapiens are tough that way yeah
I mean this is now your fourth film with
him what is it what is it about yourself
that makes you such a perfect fit for
Tim Burton's world no I feel like could
be part of his paint box you know it's
like a really cool thing I I love the
fact that we we get to work together as
much as we do and I hope we work many
many many more times together it's it's
a great feeling when he calls and says
he's got something going on and and he
wants you to be part of it so it's just
you know Dumbo has always been a
favorite of mine and I know of his to
and and to give this these great themes
the way this movie was constructed in
the 40s and you keep that to Tim Burton
who's an artist is gonna like you know
handle it with like an amazing flare and
it's going to be wonderful like
exponentially more and more artistic and
deal with the themes and preserve those
themes but just blow it out into the
stratosphere
I just
I take doing it I would do it over and
over again what
well color do you feel like you are in
Tim's symptoms I'm riddled are
definitely red do you do you notice any
similarities between the characters you
play for too
well means besides the fact a big
fishing the only thing different with
with the Medici and big fish
is you know well I guess I was a
werewolf and big fish but I am you know
the circus some presario in both movies
and and the only thing he's probably had
to let the suit out a little bit
you